Mic Check Mic Check la la blah blah
audios good hey what is going on YouTube
yes I am vlogging more yes I'm having
more conversations with the camera and I
really don't know what to talk about on
this space anymore now before when I was
doing this I was just you know laying my
opinions out on very specific things
that people would ask and mind you if
you want to get involved with these
videos ask away give me articles give me
topics um life advice that's my [ __ ]
before I would just be like ass [ __ ]
what you guys think I'm just gonna do
whatever I want what I don't think
that's what this space is for I think
it's about interaction so basically what
I'm saying is I'm just gonna talk about
whatever the [ __ ] is on my mind whether
it's dated or not people like well
people been talking about that buck you
[ __ ] is my channel nothing's dated say
whatever I want but I don't think that's
what this space is for I think it's
about interaction now this is a topic
that's been kind of like mowing in my
head is mulling a word I keep using
words that I don't know exist or not
mulling over your head in my mind in my
face but in 2017 there has been this
huge huge rising of like women empowered
films and I gotta say I kind of like it
it's different and to be honest with you
it's kind of nice now I've said this
before too like I grew up around very
very strong women specifically Asian
immigrant women see the woman that I
grew up with my mother she is kind of
like the foundation of the type of woman
I like to be with and how I view women
because you know that's first-hand
experience right my mom ran and still
runs the business with my father she
raised two kids they were working like
at the time when we started like I don't
know 70 80 plus hours a week I can't
remember exactly and still on Sundays
she made food for the church she
supported my father when he was trying
to become a pastor and on her spare time
she would [ __ ] me up so when these films
started to come out I started to read
like reviews of a lot of these like
women empowered films from the
perspective of a lot of men who kind of
view women in a different light now
there's this guy on the internet who I
actually do watch a lot and I don't
agree with half the [ __ ] that he says
but he's very compelling and I love the
way that he speaks and I
seems like a comedian but I think he's
more of like a political analyst or some
sort his name is steven crowder now
steven crowder had this video out and it
was a while back when atomic blonde came
out right now atomic blonde is basically
this secret agent woman played by
Charlize Theron who I who I [ __ ] love
Charlize if you're into overweight
chubby Korean men let me know well I
have a girlfriend but you know we talked
I said never mind oh I'm probably not to
delete this part but he kind of goes on
this rant which reflects what a lot of
men think when it came to films like
this where they said [ __ ] like there is
no [ __ ] way a girl could whup a
dude's ass like that it's so unrealistic
so what I get is [ __ ] I'm like are you
talking about it's a [ __ ] film no
[ __ ] it's unrealistic what and other is
pointy kind of Mentor superwoman but he
says it's okay with superwoman because
it's a fictional character with
superpowers
however atomic bod is also fictional
what the [ __ ] are you talking about look
I get it yeah no [ __ ]
when Charlize Theron comes up in this
one part of the film and she starts
beating the [ __ ] out of somebody with
the keel clearly that's not real but
it's not something that's just
attributed to women in action films do
you understand what I'm saying if it
doesn't bother you that Jackie Channel
what somebody's asked for the feather
duster in a pooper-scooper
I'm pretty sure you should be okay with
Charlize Theron smacking somebody's face
with the heel my god Jackie Chan's one
of my heroes but I gotta say in every
movie he makes false promises how many
times that folks say he didn't want
trouble but he still looks everybody but
I've seen a lot of street fights and I
had never seen somebody do a 360 kick to
somebody's face and everybody was like
so when people say stuff like well it's
unrealistic for women [ __ ] is
unrealistic for humans in general what
are you talking about but what in the
[ __ ] do you ever see a street fight
where [ __ ] hits are blocked exactly
for men and women it doesn't make sense
and I gotta say when I started to read
the critiques about women in film and
why they did it like it
I started to understand I started to
understand a little bit why girls get
tired of the whole like the damsel in
distress type of thing
yeah Charlize Theron's an atomic blonde
like kicking everybody's ass is it
realistic but on the other side like I
just said [ __ ] double-oh-seven
or anybody else Liam Neeson's I [ __ ]
love me and Liam's but the [ __ ]
like 50 or 60 years old killing
everybody nobody wants to see a
realistic action film [ __ ] I want to
see somebody get shot six or seven times
and somehow be able to still block it's
like Tony Montana Scarface that's what
got shot 50 times but he's still a nice
man we're like in Rocky
so Vesta said love got punched in the
face 78 times in three seconds and he
was still standing is that [ __ ]
realistic I think not but it was
entertainment as [ __ ] in fact the Rocky
films ruined actual boxing for me cuz I
found out people actually don't get hit
in the face as much they do with the
bodies [ __ ] was boring as [ __ ] they were
blocking and guarding and [ __ ] I was
like what's going on son
why can't you punch him in the face like
rocky did listen I loved Sylvester
Stallone and I loved the Rocky films but
I never understood half the [ __ ] he was
saying go to the bathroom if you want to
watch an action film that's realistic
why don't you just go [ __ ] watch you
see that's what I do and then you see
what happens in a real fight you can't
put that in a film and say that it's
going to be exciting it has to be
exaggerated so if that applies to men it
also applies to women both are
unrealistic so what does it have to do
with the [ __ ] gender I gotta say if
that's the complaint that people are
having about the women empowered films
in 2017 you're just [ __ ] you're
scratching for [ __ ] at this point you
really are it bothers you that a girl
does something that men do whether it's
realistic or not I understand physically
speaking men are stronger than women
that's why we have differently weight
classes and that's why the USC women
fight women and men fight men we all
understand that but in a fictional film
they can do whatever the [ __ ] they want
just like the male characters and what
it kind of boils down to and I hate
using this
a little bit of sexism don't you mean
that even in a fake fictitious world
that they can't even have superpowers
they can't do why why like what the [ __ ]
Lord of the Rings that one [ __ ] she
rides dragons and [ __ ] roses people
like marshmallows but that don't bother
nobody like I said I'm not going against
science I'm not saying that [ __ ] men
are weaker than women physically I you
know scientifically speaking it's not
true but it also doesn't mean that there
are women out there that could whoop the
dudes ass like have you seen Chris
cyborg that woman looks like she cracks
coconuts with her face she look like if
she want that ass it just gets me to
wonder like why why are people
threatened by that [ __ ] why are people
threatened by uplifting the other gender
and also not to bleed into another topic
but when these type of issues are
brought up a lot of people like to
generalize and categorize men it's like
one angry little cluster so it's like a
small group of men think of women in
this type of way suddenly it's all men
yeah we make jokes about it but I'm
starting to think that people actually
believe in this [ __ ] don't condemn
me for what my shitty ass peers do
condemned me for the shitty things that
I do and on the same note of where I
talk about guys who feel threatened by
uplifting women I don't believe that you
have to support what women do by
trashing what men do I think it's the
dumbest thing on earth like yeah I want
women to be strong but [ __ ] dicks listen
what white white [ __ ] dicks well
actually that would be the head a nice
but why hate men just to support what
we've been doing why hate women just to
support what men do it doesn't make
sense just because you like something
doesn't mean you automatically have to
hate something else it just it's not
everything works out that way so my
question to you out there is how do you
feel about this new trend of Hollywood
women movies do you like it do you think
it's unrealistic do you think that
people are just doing it because it's a
trend and a fad right now or do you
think that it's good for society because
I'll tell you what I don't mind watching
the video of a woman kicking my [ __ ]
ass that sounds like a fetish that's not
that's not what I meant
[Music]